they've rolled out some big beasts on
this search on planes large and small
here crews are chasing the moment the
world is waiting for on the day 10
aircraft and ten ships undertook the
hunt for flight mh370 Australia's Prime
Minister came to the airbase hub on how
long this will last he said it was
mission indefinite I'm certainly not
putting a time limit on it and we will
keep searching for quite some time to
come and as I said the intensity of our
search and the magnitude of our
operations is increasing not decreasing
it was a time to pray for the families
of those on board the missing Malaysian
airliner a group of Chinese relatives
have travelled from Beijing to Kuala
Lumpur to be closer to the investigation
it's every second a second too long for
them somewhere through your heart we the
Chinese people are friendly and
accepting but we will never tolerate
those criminals who killed our families
concealed the truth and delayed the
search and rescue efforts there has been
debris plucked from the sea but nothing
yet from the missing plane this was
material picked up by a Chinese ship a
blue plastic drum a plastic bottle and
the fishing boy the difficulty of not
losing debris once has been spotted is
demonstrated by this oceanographers
animation model similar to that used by
searchers it's based on scientific
predictions of how material is thrown
around by the tides and currents of the
Indian Ocean when Australia's Prime
Minister came here he stated this job
would be extraordinarily difficult he's
not the only one involved to stress how
hard this will be they know here the
world wants a quick result they're keen
to manage expectations downwards they
know the world wants a quick result
experience is telling them the world
will have to wait a bit longer James
Matthews Sky News in Perth Western
Australia